[MUSIC]
MALE SPEAKER 1: Shanghai GDG
is a very interesting
developer community.
FEMALE SPEAKER 1: I'm
glad somebody
has asked this question.
[INAUDIBLE]
MALE SPEAKER 2: This is where
the magic happens.
JENNY MURPHY: This is primarily
a question and
answer show.
So if any of you out there would
like to ask questions.
Hi, everyone.
Welcome to this week's session
of the Google+
Platform Office Hours.
This week we're going to field
your questions and comments
about the Hangouts API.
So before we dig into the
questions and answers, let me
introduce myself, and my
co-hosts, and my other guests.
So starting with me,
I'm Jenny Murphy.
I'm a developer programs
engineer here at Google, which
means I help you build really
cool stuff with Google+ APIs.
And other Googlers joining me
via the magic of cyberspace,
we have Jonathan Berry
on the hangout.
JONATHAN BERRY: Hi, I'm
Jonathan Berry.
I'm a developer advocate
focusing on hangouts and
Hangout apps.
JENNY MURPHY: Umhmm.
We also have Silvano.
SILVANO LUCIANI: Hi.
I'm Silvano Luciani and I'm a
developer programs engineer
working in London focusing
on Hangouts API and apps.
JENNY MURPHY: We also have
some developers who have
joined us through the
same hangout.
So from left to right.
Abraham.
ABRAHAM WILLIAMS: Hi, I'm
Abraham Williams.
I have a start-up in San
Francisco called Addvocate.
I'm constantly hacking on
different and various projects.
And I've been having fun
watching all the Mars news in
the last couple of days.
JENNY MURPHY: And Allen.
ALLEN FIRSTENBERG: Hi there.
I'm Allen Firstenberg.
I'm an independent developer
in New York.
I tend to work a lot with the
Hangout API, and I've started
dabbling with the History
API a little bit.
JENNY MURPHY: Next is Emily.
EMILY SOLDAL: I'm a software
engineer at Google.
I've only recently started
there, so I've actually had a
lot of experience externally
poking at the APIs.
JENNY MURPHY: And that's the
nature of a lot of our
favorite developers end up
deciding to join us.
EMILY SOLDAL: It's
a good place.
JENNY MURPHY: Yah, not bad.
Gerwin.
GERWIN STURM: Ya, hi, I'm
Gerwin from Austria.
I'm developing all sorts of
stuff with the different
Google+ APIs.
JENNY MURPHY: Great.
And last but not least, Matt
who got an invite about 10
minutes ago.
MATT VAN VEENENDAAL:
Hey, guys.
I'm Matt.
I work here at Curious Minds.
I'm just really kind of playing
around with the Google
Hangouts API and seeing what
we can do with it.
JENNY MURPHY: That's great.
So I guess without
further ado--
Actually, Jonathan, did you
mention you had something you
wanted to chat about before
we dove into the
questions and answers?
JONATHAN BERRY: Oh yeah, sure,
just a brief update on our
favorite robot friend--
favorite hangout-enabled
robot friend.
Today he made Hack a Day,
which was a real treat.
Of course, he came back, took
down Gus's servers, but
they're back up.
[LAUGHTER]
JONATHAN BERRY: But, it's
a fun use case.
I think people love robots.
Clearly people love
hangouts, though.
It's a match made in heaven.
JENNY MURPHY: Yes.
OSCAR was a lot of fun
to show all of you.
And in case any of you are
wondering, the source code for
OSCAR was just published to our
Office Hours Repository,
which I'll link to from the show
notes in case you were
eagerly awaiting that
source code.
It is up there.
And you'll be surprised
how simple it is.
Maybe.
Well, without further ado, let's
dive into the questions.
So I believe Matt, you had
some hangouts questions.
MATT VAN VEENENDAAL:
Yeah, awesome.
So I've been working with
hangouts quite a bit over the
last few weeks, and I have a
couple of questions here that
I'd really like to kind
of get through.
The first and possibly most
important one is one of the
problems I'm having with my
hangout is when people can
choose Chat, or they choose
another app for example.
It really kind of kills
my app, and I don't
know where it goes.
Is there any way we can have
like a hook or some kind of
vent that's driven
where my app is
unloaded on the user side?
Or perhaps you know of some way
to change the UI so that
we can notify the user ahead
of time when pressing Chat.
Or something like that that
would kick out of the app
that's running.
JONATHAN BERRY: Sure.
So there's the two scenarios
you talked about.
One is about Chat.
And one is about
switching apps.
And one is actually about
turning off an app.
And that's two different
use cases.
When the Chat is enabled, it
shouldn't have any effect on
the functionality of
your application.
And that might just be a bug.
I have yet to see that or
hear reports of that.
So if you're able to
repeat it, please,
let's dive into that.
MATT VAN VEENENDAAL: Yeah, just
to quickly clarify that
while we're on that.
It's actually because my app
runs in the side pane-- like
it's one of the side
pane apps.
JONATHAN BERRY: Oh, it's
an extension app.
Yeah.
With an extension app, you can
only have the Chat or an
extension type app running
at the same time.
That's by design.
It's just because of real estate
and things like that.
I was going to say that for our
standard application, we
have events related to
participants enabling or
disabling your app.
So on Participant Enabled we'll
tell you when somebody
switches to another app or
switches back to the camera.
And when you close the app,
there's no event for that.
But in your particular case with
the extension type app,
it's really an all or nothing.
There may be an event
listed for that.
Silvano, do you know?
SILVANO LUCIANI: No.
MATT VAN VEENENDAAL: So
let's say I didn't do
an extension app.
Let's say I moved into
the main pane.
I sort of had a similar problem
when people were, for
example, clicking on
thumbnails and
bringing up the main view.
Are you saying that in that
case, these kind of
[INAUDIBLE]
Participant Disabled?
Would that be fired on
the actual client?
Or would it be fired
on everyone else's?
JONATHAN BERRY: Ahh, that would
be fired on a client.
Yeah.
MATT VAN VEENENDAAL: So with
that, one thing I was looking
at for that is potentially as
they click the thumbnail
sending the user an alert or
something like that or some
kind of visual for you to say,
hey, the Chat's gone away.
Something happened.
Would I be able to do that from
Participant Disabled?
JONATHAN BERRY: Yes.
Let me just pull up the
particulars of how
you want to do that.
Say, if you go to the
documentation, there's the
Participant Enabled Events.
MATT VAN VEENENDAAL: Mm-hm.
JONATHAN BERRY: Right.
MATT VAN VEENENDAAL: One thing I
noticed about those, though,
they seem to fire for everyone
in the hangout.
And in this particular case, I
only want to fire the event
for the person that actually
clicks on the thumbnail.
JONATHAN BERRY: Interesting.
So you have an application and
it's taking up the full frame.
And that user then clicks on the
thumbnail to view somebody
and the app gets hidden.
So you want that particular
user to know that they've
disabled the app?
MATT VAN VEENENDAAL:
Yeah, exactly.
I want them to say like,
hey, you know you've
disabled the app.
You're no longer doing
something with
whatever my app is doing.
JONATHAN BERRY: Interesting.
There may not be a hook
for that right now.
SILVANO LUCIANI: [GRUNT]
JONATHAN BERRY: That's
something to
take back to the team.
GERWIN STURM: I think there
should be an On App visible
event which might fire.
I'm not sure.
I haven't used this event.
But there's an On App visible
event which might fire.
But, of course, I think the app
should be running in the
background, so it should still
be able to respond somehow.
And then you could just
put out like a
notification on top.
Which might work.
But I'm not sure.
JONATHAN BERRY: Yeah.
So there's the On App visible.
MATT VAN VEENENDAAL: So I guess
that could clarify the
question then is, when I click
on the thumbnails, does that
actually put the app
to the background?
Or does that remove the
app completely?
JONATHAN BERRY: Correct.
The iframe is actually
still running.
MATT VAN VEENENDAAL: OK.
JONATHAN BERRY: There's really,
as far as I know, only
one way to really--
sorry.
Two ways to stop an app.
One is to close the hangout
all together.
And one is to actually go to the
app switch at the bottom,
and there's a little x that
allows the user to close it.
And it'll actually delete the
iframe-- essentially ending
the session for that
application.
MATT VAN VEENENDAAL: OK.
ALLEN FIRSTENBERG: If you switch
to a different app, it
leaves the first app running?
It leaves the first iframe
in the background?
JONATHAN BERRY: I believe so.
MATT VAN VEENENDAAL:
OK, that's cool.
So what I'll do is I'll try not
using the extension app.
Because I think the extension
app has different
functionality where it just
kind of disappears.
And I don't know
where it goes.
JONATHAN BERRY: Yeah, the way we
think about extension apps
is, it's sort of an
enhancement to the
conversation.
So if you look at one of Allen's
first apps where he
had a little text overlay, that
sort of adds to the video
conversation.
It's not really [INAUDIBLE]
with the experience.
Cameron has a very similar one,
Pro Studio, where the
conversation is center.
If you really want to have a
rich application, I'd still
have the main video.
We also have the
video overlay.
ALLEN FIRSTENBERG: My example's
actually a bad
example, because it is a full
app that embeds its own video
overlay into it.
So it has better control
over the videos.
JONATHAN BERRY: OK.
Cool.
MATT VAN VEENENDAAL: Yeah.
I'm sure I could probably
reproduce my app by just
putting a video canvas there.
I just thought the extension
seemed easier.
JONATHAN BERRY: From an API
point of view, they have the
exact same functionality, but
there is different behavior on
the canvas itself.
MATT VAN VEENENDAAL: OK.
That answers my question
for that one.
Should I go ahead and ask
my next questions?
Or should I let some of the
other guests ask theirs first?
JONATHAN BERRY: Go for it.
MATT VAN VEENENDAAL: OK.
So I have a question that's
kind of been on the
Discussions.
It was just brought up.
Is there any way to disable
the invite system?
Or disable the invite system
when you're joining?
A great example of this is--
someone brought it up on the
Discussions that the NFL fantasy
league has invented
hangouts now in their
kind of application.
But they don't let you invite
from other sources.
Like they don't let anyone from
Google+ kind of invite
the usual way.
And the reason why I would want
to do this is, let's say
I'm embedding it in an
application of my own.
I don't want to have just random
Google+ users join.
I just want to make sure
I know who's joined.
JONATHAN BERRY: Not really.
ALLEN FIRSTENBERG: And in
particular, make them join
with a particular app
already running.
MATT VAN VEENENDAAL: Yeah.
App [INAUDIBLE] would
be great.
ALLEN FIRSTENBERG: And this is
something we discussed in the
past as well.
JONATHAN BERRY: Yeah.
So there's no way to disable the
invites of functionality
of the hangout.
In general, there's sort of the
core hangout experience.
It can only be controlled
in some way.
So, for example, you can
mute the mike, you
can lower the volume.
But you can't, let's say,
prevent somebody from unmuting
themselves.
And that extends to
the invite flow.
There is some interesting
solutions to getting people
into hangout versus
preventing them.
I think Aces Poker does this
where they use the Hangout
URL, and they send that
back to their server.
And they show the active or base
step's algorithm to the
most interesting hangout
on their site.
And they guide people to
go to that hangout.
They actually refresh
the hangout itself.
MATT VAN VEENENDAAL: Yeah.
So in terms of that, I have no
problem getting people into
the hangout.
Like I can grab the hangout URL,
and I can append my app
ID, and get people in.
The question I'm concerned is
from a user point of view.
I really don't want to have the
users in there, and then
try to invite people in that
don't have my app open.
JONATHAN BERRY: Yeah.
Unfortunately, that's
not available today.
And it's a great feature
request.
The first things come to mind--
besides finding that
bug and trying to get
that prioritized--
is so now enforcing that in
the app functionality.
So basically to say, hey, you
don't have access to the app,
because you're not on some
magical list that you enforce
on your server side.
MATT VAN VEENENDAAL: Yes, that's
what I'm doing with
using that the muting
functionality
and stuff like that.
So I'll mute people
who don't have the
app open, for example.
But they can still see what's
going on in the app because I
can't really mute everyone
like that.
I can only mute what people
come in to see.
JONATHAN BERRY: Sure.
What I was actually suggesting
is going one step further.
So if they have the app running,
to actually disable
the functionality of
the app entirely?
MATT VAN VEENENDAAL: Well,
the thing is--
JONATHAN BERRY: Hey, you're not
allowed to use this app.
Please go away.
MATT VAN VEENENDAAL: Yeah.
I mean that's easy.
The problem I have is when
people join that don't have
the app running.
Because they're still able to
see other people's feeds.
I can mute them.
If someone's running the app, I
can mute anyone who doesn't
have the app.
But I can't prevent them from
seeing what's going on in the
mainstream.
JONATHAN BERRY: Yeah,
that's a great idea.
MATT VAN VEENENDAAL: So kind
of the best thing for that
would be, what?
To file a bug report?
JONATHAN BERRY: Yeah.
So we have the Google+
platform bug tracker.
And of course, we also take the
feedback directly from the
Office Hours in [INAUDIBLE].
MATT VAN VEENENDAAL: Awesome.
OK.
JONATHAN BERRY: If the bug is in
there, obviously it'll help
us get it out faster.
MATT VAN VEENENDAAL: And then
I guess my final question is
completely related to this.
This could easily be solved
by like some kind of kick
functionality or something
like that.
Is there any plans for
that at the moment?
Or should I be digging through
issue reports to see if
someone else has suggested it?
JONATHAN BERRY: Yeah.
There's definitely good
suggestions around better
moderation tools.
We launched the Cameraman
app as an example
of moderation tools.
We're investigating it.
We have nothing to announce or
anything really concrete to
talk about today.
But there's definitely
been feedback around.
Both for the end-users how
to have a better Hangout
experience for both
communication and broadcast,
as well as exposing [INAUDIBLE]
developers.
MATT VAN VEENENDAAL: Yeah.
Do you guys have a timeline
for the 1.2 release?
I know that 1.1's been
around since I've
started working on it.
Do you know when anything
like new will be up?
JONATHAN BERRY: We don't have
a regular release cycle.
I think we should walk through
how the release cycle happens.
Which makes it a little
bit more complicated.
Because there's a
Google+ plug-in.
Let's say we decide on a new
functionality and we want to
introduce that.
So the plug-in-team has to go
in, and decide the best way to
make it optimal and what
features should be enabled and
how the API server
should look.
And it gets built-- deployed.
At that point, once it's in
staging or whatever, the
Hangout apps platform team
then goes and starts
working with it.
And creates the job surface.
So that tends to increase the
amount of time it takes to
release, so things can
be very flexible.
But in general, we're going
to try to get some low
[INAUDIBLE] fruit
out pretty soon.
[INAUDIBLE] hangout.
MATT VAN VEENENDAAL: Awesome.
That answers all of
my questions.
Thank you.
Thank you, guys, again
for your time.
JONATHAN BERRY: Sorry.
I don't know if you're
talking about.
But can you say what
you're working on?
Or it's still on the DL?
MATT VAN VEENENDAAL: It's
still on the DL.
But hopefully it'll
be done soon.
JONATHAN BERRY: Cool.
Cool.
All right.
Awesome.
Thanks for the questions.
JENNY MURPHY: Great.
Yeah, thanks for the
great questions.
So does anyone else in the
hangout have anything they'd
like to ask Jonathan,
Silvano, or myself?
ABRAHAM WILLIAMS: This isn't
exactly a Hangout API
question, but I'm just curious
if you guys know anything
about the relation of the
Hangout technology and WebRTC?
JONATHAN BERRY: So WebRTC
and hangouts?
Yeah.
So Google and a bunch of other
companies have been pushing
the WebRTC standard.
It sort of started with us and
a few of our technologies we
acquired when we open sourced.
And it's definitely part of
the open web platform.
And we're moving towards
making that sort of an
available standard
for developers.
Definitely the Hangouts team has
been looking into it and
talking to our [INAUDIBLE].
Obviously it's in
Google projects.
There's some challenges there.
The spec doesn't have proper
support [INAUDIBLE] video.
It doesn't have the data channel
thing really baked in.
There's a proposal for that.
But that's the future of online
web communication, and
we hope to allign ourselves
sometime in the future.
ABRAHAM WILLIAMS: Awesome.
Thanks.
JONATHAN BERRY: OK.
No problem.
And it's fun.
I play with getUserMedia
all the time.
ABRAHAM WILLIAMS: Hah.
JONATHAN BERRY: I don't
know if you guys saw
the xylophone demo?
SILVANO LUCIANI: Yeah.
That's very, very cool.
JONATHAN BERRY: For those who
are watching and haven't seen
it, it's a great--
I think it's on HTML5 Rocks.
Or one of the other
HTML sites.
Where it's using getUserMedia
and some sort of a
handtracking, and you can
play a xylophone.
On the screen.
EMILY SOLDAL: Awesome.
JONATHAN BERRY: Yeah,
it's fun.
SILVANO LUCIANI: Yeah.
If you're interested in the
WebRTC, I think last week,
there was an Office Hours from
the Chrome Developer relation
team from London.
So you should be able to
find it in the GDL.
In Google Developers slide.
SEVERAL PERSONS: Excellent.
JONATHAN BERRY: It was a great
talk with Sam Dutton and I
think some of the product
managers--
SILVANO LUCIANI: Yes.
JONATHAN BERRY: --or
the tech leads.
SILVANO LUCIANI: Yeah, I think
Bid Labash as well was there.
ALLEN FIRSTENBERG: This
is more of a best
practices type question.
Are there any best suggested
ways for dealing with
maintaining a--
one of the things I tend to find
a lot, and I'm sure a lot
of other developers do as well,
is maintaining a list of
people who are in a
queue for example.
For a game or whatever.
And that queue is stored
in the shared state.
Occasionally a person
will leave.
Either quit the app or leave
a hangout or whatever.
The person needs to be removed
from the shared state.
Is there any best practice about
figuring out who does
that removal?
Or should every client try to
remove it at the same time?
And you get a cascade of people
all submitting the same
change to the shared state?
JONATHAN BERRY: I remember when
we first launched, there
was a dev, I believe his name
was Matt Center, or still is
Matt Center, and he built a very
simple JavaScript client
for client side state machines
that integrated with the
shared state.
And I think that the short
answer there is the best
practice is to figure out.
So for example, if you have
a leader in a game--
I mean you just have all the
work done but the leader.
And the leader could just simply
be the first person to
join the hangout.
You just sign that as a leader
and that client does all the
heavy lifting.
SILVANO LUCIANI: [INAUDIBLE].
GERWIN STURM: Ya.
Then you only have a problem if
the current leader leaves
the hanger.
Then you have to decide
[INAUDIBLE] the next one
[INAUDIBLE].
That's the problem
JONATHAN BERRY: You
want to queue--
ALLEN FIRSTENBERG: In this
situation, you've got a queue.
So if the first person in the
queue does all the work and if
the first person's not the one
who's there, then the second
person does all the work.
So in this case, it's
established.
But it sounds like with the
general case of best
practices, having one person
submit deltas instead of
having everybody submit
a delta--
the same delta--
is the better solution.
JONATHAN BERRY: One of the
functionalities I think we
added in 1.0--
or just one of the
pieces of data.
We had participant order ID.
Order?
I forgot the exact--
it's the order that that person
joints the hangout.
So that's a lightweight way.
You can use that
for assigning.
Display Index.
That's what it is.
So I've used--
EMILY SOLDAL: [INAUDIBLE].
And why is the light
going [INAUDIBLE]--
JENNY MURPHY: Sounds good.
EMILY SOLDAL: It's really light
here, so all the lights
keep turning off.
JENNY MURPHY: That happens.
That whole environmentalism
thing.
So great.
So good to know.
I'm probably going to pull some
questions in from the
stream once we come back.
Once we wrap up that question.
It's still active.
I don't think we quite
finished it.
Sorry?
Wait.
We are live again, everyone.
So hey, everyone
on the stream.
Thanks for hanging out.
Sorry, we lost the stream
for a moment.
And where were we on
that question?
Would you like to repeat
the question?
ALLEN FIRSTENBERG: The question
was, I think, under
what circumstances would
Display Index be No?
JONATHAN BERRY: Yes.
Well, we started with
best practices
for managing a queue.
And basically, if you have one
operation that we really only
need to do once, how do you
manage [INAUDIBLE] everybody?
And one suggestion that I gave
was, I use the Display Index.
Because that is a simple,
lightweight way to pick who's
the leader and display zero.
Index equals zero.
It could be the person
who always acts.
So Display Index.
In the documentation, we
state that Display
Index can be Null.
That may be related
to the Cameraman.
And I think we should have
to figure out on our own.
Do a little experimentation and
we can update that in the
show notes.
SILVANO LUCIANI: Yeah.
JENNY MURPHY: Great.
Cool.
So I have one question from
the YouTube comments.
PlaidGaming is wondering how
they can improve their
experience with streaming
game feeds.
I guess into a hangout.
So specifically, PlaidGaming
asks, is there a way to make
the content of their streaming
to the hangout full screen?
JONATHAN BERRY: So, can you make
your streaming content
full screen?
So in general, the hangouts can
be, in certain operating
systems, maximized to the full
frame of the operating system.
But the core content cannot
be broken out.
So as you scale out the full
screen, the hangout
information at the top and the
line controls, they all go to
the top of the screen.
And the [INAUDIBLE]
goes to the bottom
of the screen.
And the core camera--
or core frame--
gets bigger.
But that can never be
the full screen.
That's a good use case for
streaming, but it's less
interesting when you're talking
about hangout in
conversation.
But I understand where
you're coming from.
But unfortunately, you
can't do that today.
JENNY MURPHY: So great idea.
So keep those ideas coming.
So that's it for our questions
from the stream right now.
So does anyone else in the
hangout have a question they'd
like to ask?
EMILY SOLDAL: Yeah, I do
actually have a question.
Last week we talked about
the History API.
I sometimes started thinking
about this, and in moments in
the History APIs, it's pretty
much the smallest iota of
shareable data.
And we talked a little
bit about
collation of these moments.
One thing I'm curious about is
if there's likely to be any
way for us to [INAUDIBLE] those
moments as a set of
things that happened.
And produce a story
out of them.
Like will there be some
sort of way to share
more than one moment?
As a collection basically.
Because as it stands right now,
if you generate a moment,
that moment without
context doesn't
have that much meaning.
JENNY MURPHY: Understood.
So you're asking about from the
Google+ interface, once we
have all those moments into your
history, what interesting
things you'll be able
to do with them.
Is that right?
EMILY SOLDAL: Yes.
But not only that.
You will have to be
able to supply the
context from the API.
So--
correlation and stuff-- if
you'll be able to use groups
of moments together.
JENNY MURPHY: So,
programmatically accessing.
She's asking about problematical
accessing the
moments that are part
of the history.
And accessing them
via aggregation?
This is an interesting
question.
So we've talked a little bit on
our Past Office Hours about
getting feedback from all of
you about what we want the
Google+ interface and
applications to do with
moments once they're in there.
And this is a similar kind of
question, except it's about
programmatic accessing
of that.
And this is something
we haven't really
thought a lot about.
And one of the things in the
Developer Preview that we'd
like to hear from you.
So let me flip this
one back at you.
Assuming you had a Read API or
a List API of some kind, how
would you want to be able
to access the moments in
interesting ways?
As an application developer, how
would you want to be able
to group a moments and filter
them and that kind of stuff?
EMILY SOLDAL: Well, if you're
pulling the raw moments from
the stream, it's going to be
very much like a firehose.
You're going to get a lot of
microdata that don't really
relate to each other.
Because you're going to
get all the things you
[INAUDIBLE], and all the things
you viewed, and all the
things you walked past because
you have the app on that
tracks things that
you walk past.
I don't know.
It's going to be too much.
So being able to sort of provide
some sort of context.
Say, for example, I want not
just a search in sort
of time, but also--
that would be the logical thing
to say, give me the
first hundred.
Or give me the ones for the
past week or something.
But if you want to say, I want
all the moments that have to
do with when I was in Barcelona,
for example.
Like all the moments that were
generated under this
particular umbrella context.
And then being able to look at
those and say OK, well, I
generated a context when I went
on holiday, for example.
And then all the pictures I
took when I was on holiday
falls underneath this moments.
All the music I listened to
become the soundtrack for
these moments.
So they show up.
All the places I
checked in at.
And the places I reviewed,
and the restaurants that
I ate at, and stuff.
And how I can go, well, these
are sort of the contextual
events that happened.
And then if I could pull out
those as groups of moments,
you could do some very
interesting things
with that, I think.
JENNY MURPHY: It's a
really cool idea.
GERWIN STURM: So what I've been
thinking in this regard.
In the API, you already
have this collection.
Which at the moment, is
only the [INAUDIBLE].
So maybe if you just opened
this collection, so it can
create your own collection.
So you can make one collection
for your vacation.
And then you set
the [INAUDIBLE]
standard for the time when
you're on vacation and all the
moments are written into this
special collection.
Because you have this kind of
collection thing planned in
some way, it seems.
JENNY MURPHY: Hmm.
That's a cool point.
I [INAUDIBLE] like that idea
of using collections.
Although I'm wondering if that
would be a sufficiently rich
way to describe them.
Because a collection of moments
has many different
kind of contexts on
different axes.
As Emily mentioned,
kind of an event.
Which has a geographic location
and potentially like
time boundaries.
Like a cluster of moments
that occur in a
certain period of time.
But they're also going to be
like all the moments it
occurred when I was in my car,
and all the moments that
occurred when I was outside.
So there's a lot of different
axes that you could use to
slice and see this data
in interesting ways.
So I guess this is a call to all
you developers out there
in general.
This is the kind of
feedback we want.
Please share it via
any channel.
Via hangouts like we're doing
right now, in the discussion
group, in our issue tracker.
If there are ways that you'd
like to be able to
programmatically access and
process all those moments in
your user's history,
please keep that
feedback coming to us.
And we will sort it out, and try
and come up with something
that will be really interesting
to you guys.
So you guys can write some
really cool applications.
So, thanks.
Let's take a look at the
stream right now.
We have another comment
also from PlaidGaming.
It's about the same topic of
streaming content, sharing
content, into a hangout.
And PlaidGaming asks, is there
any way to make the latency of
the stream less latent?
Make it faster.
JONATHAN BERRY: Ahh, so as
latency of the stream.
Improve the latency
of the stream.
I wish there was a little more
specifics around that.
Because it is a pretty
complex topic.
Specifically, if he's doing a
screen share for example,
that's limited at the FPS.
If you [INAUDIBLE] application,
[INAUDIBLE]
screen share, [INAUDIBLE]
the stream.
So that's a functionality of the
screen share capabilities.
If he is using a webcam, or a
hardware capture card, or a
software capture card on a
faster machine, then the
latency of the stream
basically is
dependent on two things.
One, the performance of the
machine and by the connection.
And Hangouts uses a variable
codec that changes
dynamically--
compression and a bunch
of other things--
so that can go up and down.
If you're on a fast connection
and you have a fast machine,
and you're using an external
hardware capture card for
video game console, the stream
should be very good.
Especially if you're connecting
with local
participants.
If you are in a good
time of the day.
In general, we've seen pretty
good performance on all those
forms with all those variables
under control.
Now if there's something
specific you're saying, hey,
my particular machine is
not performing well.
Maybe it's a Linux box and you
have an out-of-date plug-in.
That could be affecting
things.
Obviously, if you have a slow
Internet connection, you're
not getting the best performance
on that codec.
But I can't think of anything in
particular without specific
issues to troubleshoot.
ALLEN FIRSTENBERG: Can you
address briefly the
differences in latency between
Submit Delta and Send Message?
JONATHAN BERRY: From the
API point of view?
ALLEN FIRSTENBERG: Yes.
JONATHAN BERRY: OK, cool.
So different direction all
together about API versus the
video stream.
So Submits Delta.
So we have the data
[INAUDIBLE]
APIs, which is composed of two
types of APIs right now.
One is a Shared State Model
and one is a High Speed
UDP-like Model.
In the Shared State, there's
a few things going on.
One, you're writing a key value
pair to a small shared
state's memory somewhere
in the cloud.
And we guarantee delivery of
that key to the cloud.
And not only that, we guarantee
delivery of events
that's been changed
to [INAUDIBLE].
With all those guarantees,
there's a bit of latency
associated with it, but it's
going over the same channel
that the video and the Send
Message or high-speed API's
going over.
But that's great for in-game
persistence.
So a counter, a level,
a type of cursor.
Anything that's lightweight that
you just want to track
for that game.
It's fast-ish.
That's the best way to put it.
We're seeing around
300 milliseconds.
But it's not real time.
It is fast, but it's
not real time.
That is [INAUDIBLE].
Now we introduced in, I believe,
1.1, the Send Message
API, which is as fast as
we can send an API.
And that is a different
distribution model.
There is no shared state.
But what it actually does is
send a message to every
participate but yourself.
And we send that out as quickly
as possible to all
participants.
Because it's UDP-like,
it is [INAUDIBLE].
So there's no guarantee
of packets being sent.
So if you're sending one packet
and you want to make
sure that's getting there, Send
Message is probably not
the best medium.
Most likely what you're going to
do is, actually use Shared
State and Send Message
in a lot of cases.
For example, let's say you have
a drawing app, and you
have this nice curve.
You're recording the actual
curve maybe as data points in
the string, and you keep on
pushing up the shared state.
But because of the delay, you
want to actually have that
smoother, so you'll combine that
with the Send Message to
update every participant while
it's being happening.
And then do a little bit
of data correction--
which is a common technique
for video games.
So if you drop a packet and
then the next frame you'll
update it and smooth that out.
And it's usually happening
faster than the eye can see.
Then you get that smooth curve
[INAUDIBLE] synchronized.
That's sort of the high-end
detail level description of
Send Message versus
Shared State.
ALLEN FIRSTENBERG: I think you
said you were getting about
300 milliseconds with
the Shared State.
What kind of latency are you
seeing on the Send Message?
JONATHAN BERRY: They're both
going to be variable.
I should say that.
But we usually see a
factor like 2 to 3.
So a good machine that has good
connections, I've seen on
average 300 milliseconds for
Shared State and 100
milliseconds for Send Message.
And I have seen that
fluctuate.
So depending on load in the
system, the particular
[INAUDIBLE] node you're
connecting to, that
may go up or down.
But in general, we're getting
pretty consistent marks that
100-200 on the Send Message,
and 300-500--
really, really bad--
on Shared State.
And I really haven't seen
very much of that.
Just some minor reports.
JENNY MURPHY: Great.
So I see one other comment
from the feed on YouTube.
William Brian comments in
regards to the previous
conversation we just had about
being able to read moments in
interesting ways
programmatically, he describes
it as a search problem.
And describes one potential
option as a special collection
with a start and end date.
So, yeah, this is definitely
a great option.
There are a lot of different
ways you could
slice or dice these.
So if you think of specifically
applications you
want to write, and very specific
use cases, those are
most helpful to us.
So when you're thinking about
how you'd like to cluster
those moments, definitely,
please give us--
use cases help us a lot.
Figure out how that fits
in the big picture.
So thanks.
And poking around the streams,
I don't see many other
comments right now.
So are there any other questions
from people who've
joined us in the hangout?
Doesn't sound like it.
So I guess we will
call it a day.
So thanks, everyone who's
watching on the stream.
And thanks everyone who joined
from the hangout.
JONATHAN BERRY: Thanks, guys.
JENNY MURPHY: So until next
week, see you later.
Bye.
[MUSIC PLAYING]